une nouvelle unité de production une
usine une vraie c'est désormais ici dans
la zone aéroportuaire que gérard rangama
poursuit une aventure débutée il ya une
vingtaine d'années une visite de ses
nouveaux locaux s'imposer et c'est le
conseiller départemental en charge de
l'agriculture qui a voulu comprendre les
secrets de la transformation des
produits agricoles locaux par soleil
règne ici donc la ccpo l'avait
chaussures réseau de production et
ensuite plusieurs chambres froides
permettent le stockage de produits frais
comme ici les fruits
mais pour le giron de soleil réunion il
faut aussi trouver des solutions pour
écouler le surplus de produits fruits ou
légumes tout en innovant en recherchant
des produits rares
si par exemple revirement
par exemple
marc savard
roubaix et de cons
c'est un petit tu continues tu as
production d'exactement l'egypte harel
qui sont à faire dès cette fin d'année
on va prendre de la pub des letchis
baba figues bohème lentilles de cilaos
ses produits plaisent autant dans notre
île qu'à l'exportation l'exportation la
cie le principal de soleil définir la
conceptualisations c'est ce que j'ai su
faire depuis une vingtaine d'années à
cette date et surtout d'avoir une vision
la vision de la réunion de son
agriculture de sa jeunesse de sa
population de la démographie de la marge
de manoeuvre que nous avons en termes de
développement agricole est également la
vision en termes de développement
commercial à la fois la réunion à moyen
et à long terme et aussi à l'export en
europe plus principalement puisque l'on
va dire c'est notre terrain de jeu c'est
là où je suis intervenu depuis
maintenant une vingtaine d'années pour
faire des expérimentations voir si
vraiment les produits réunionnais plaît
ou pas aux consommateurs européens
donc aujourd'hui les résultats sont
positifs les essais sont concluants
raison pour laquelle nous avons passé du
stade amateurs au stade professionnel
pour le conseil départemental soleil
réunion un modèle économique qui a su
créer de l'emploi mais surtout
consolider son activité
un exemple à suivre ceci chez un
passionné un passionné c'est un peu
comme nous en politique il faut y croire
et monsieur rangama 3 y croit depuis 20
ans et aujourd'hui il nous présente le
fleuron de ce qu'il a pu réaliser
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et c'est une
réussite
on revenait à 250 tonnes de produits
locaux transformés dans les ateliers de
soleil réunion ça montre bien qui a un
savoir faire local qui nous faut
accompagner qu'il nous faut encourager
et je crois que le lien est trouvé entre
la production agricole et l'unité de
transformation avec un put un effectif
un effectif d'autant plus intéressant
que je sais du personnel en insertion
qui est dans ses cuisines et qui
aujourd'hui est en train de venir des
professionnels genre je crois aussi ça
monte aussi toute l'évolution possible
qu'on peut avoir sur l'encadrement sur
l'accompagnement de nos jeunes
une entreprise qui réussit car la suée
également mettre l'humain au service de
son activité depuis plus de 20 ans
gérard
accompagner les jeunes en difficulté en
les insérant dans son autre crise c'est
quand même personne dans l'administratif
et en danses locales on est deux quatre
six huit personnes grand maximum avec le
responsable également gms qui va nous
rejoindre tout à l'heure et puis il ya
la partie également de production
derrière une dizaine de jeunes la
déception une bonne personne
les livreurs j'ai dit et puis les
magasins les animations qui s'était donc
au total on monte à 25 voire une
transmission des pointes c'est ça dure
une trentaine en fin d'année puis
métropole salon de l'agriculture on a un
groupe de jeunes également sur paris je
suis composé de valeurs valeurs sociales
valeurs solidarité valeurs familiales
valeurs d'authenticité avec les produits
de la réunion
donc c'est cela qui composent bon ma
personne
l'implication associative avec les
jeunes etc etc cette initiative que j'ai
toujours su garder dans mon évolution
parce que j'estime que la réunion bien
sûr il faut des élites
il faut des bons produits mais il faut
aussi intégrer la jeunesse
même si cette jeunesse est en difficulté
et elle compose aussi le développement
de la réunion donc pour moi c'est
primordial d'avoir ses piliers la de
développement achard bafing qui manque
confie piment oiseau rouge car ils
poulet fumé 23 ans guybrush l on va être
marin autant de saveurs qui sentent bon
la réunion et puis il ya les
incontournables confiture goyavier
tomates vanille et l'excellent nasri de
la passion primé au salon de
l'agriculture
après avoir investi l'aéroport
roland-garros sur la réunion selon ce
nouveau défi avec comme objectif mais
tant les uns de produits pays mais
également met en l'air le savoir faire
réunionnais